大家好，我是 Andrew Mayne，欢迎收听
Open AI 播客。 在今天的节目中，
我们将与研究主管 Tej
Jal Patwardhan 讨论
随着旧基准测试的饱和，构建更严格的评估的必要性
。
总体来说很糟糕。 基准测试是不好的。 如何
让这些模型对
人们的实际工作有所帮助？ 我们当时真的很
紧张，因为我们觉得
人类的基准线很难确定。 我们不
知道该模型能否胜过它。
但我们绝不应低估该
模型。
Tej Jal，我有个问题。
你是怎么走到今天这一步的？ 是什么
让你加入OpenAI？
哦，我还以为我们不会从
这个开始呢。
Tej Jal，我有个问题想问你。
你想从哪里开始？
嗯，我们能不能先请你讲讲
你刚加入 OpenAI 时都做了些什么，
然后倒叙一下你的工作经历？
你现在想聊聊你的早期经历吗
？
不，我是在 OpenAI 长大的。 这就像是
自然而然的“
好的”。  [笑声]
嗯，跟我说说你在
人工智能领域，在 OpenAI 工作的经历吧。
所以，我在 2023 年秋季加入了 OpenAI，当时正值
ChatGPT 发布之后不久。
GPT-4 发布后，OpenAI 也成立了
超级对齐团队，我加入了这个
准备团队，当时
我们开始
研究这些模型的能力
发展到什么程度，并思考
下一代模型
会是什么样子。 当时这
非常令人兴奋，因为就在
我加入之后不久，
推理模型的一些早期成果
开始显现，我们当时就在
想，如果这些模型
真的发展起来，未来的
能力会是什么样子，我们该如何
为未来做好准备呢？ 因此，我们做了
很多关于威胁建模
以及我们应该运行哪些评估等方面的工作
？ 我们如何考虑发布
这样的模型？ 现在
加入正是绝佳时机。
是什么让你对这个领域感兴趣？
是的，对我来说，评估真的令人
兴奋，因为它们是一种
衡量和了解我们的
模型能做什么并看到进展的方法，你
知道，这往往是在进展发生之前。
比如有这样一个术语叫做能力
过剩，指的是
模型在
人们真正采用并
利用其功能之前很久就已经具备了某些能力。 比如
，你知道，即使在某项能力尚未准备就绪之前，使用它也可能存在
文化、法律或监管方面的障碍
。 因此，能够通过
评估来帮助开发和衡量我们的模型，可以帮助你真正
了解这项技术的功能，
并在未来发生之前预见未来
，这非常
有趣。 而且我认为这也很
重要，因为它可以帮助
世界为正在发生的事情做好准备。
就像我最初
来这里的时候，我之所以对参与
一些
准备评估工作感到非常兴奋，部分原因是我认为
这些模型的能力越来越强，
而且我觉得我
现实生活中的很多朋友并不真正
理解这些模型
很快就会变得多么强大，因为他们会看看
聊天 GPT 的输出，然后说：
“是啊，这简直是胡言乱语，一点
也不智能，读起来
就像人工智能的垃圾。” 这就好比是，“好吧，
这是现在的情况，但问题在于
斜率。如果斜率非常高，
那么变化发生的速度可能
比人们预期的要快得多。”
所以我认为我们能做的最伟大的服务之一
就是衡量并
与世界分享进步的模样，
尤其是因为在
人们
真正理解和感受到进步之前，往往存在这种能力过剩的情况。 嗯，
还有模型本身。 嗯，
所以我觉得
这一切都非常重要，部分原因就在于此。
推理是一个激动人心的时刻，
但对世界上大多数人来说，
直到一年后
他们才发现这一点。 但
你突然
明白，即使尺寸没有变大，如果给模型
更长的时间思考，就能
得到更好的结果，这种感觉是怎样的呢？
那段时间真的非常开心。 我的意思是，嗯，
在一些早期实验中（
我们刚才也讨论过），
模型似乎只是用
数学进行训练的。 我记得当时有一系列
实验，Nat McClees 说：
“嘿，这个模型是用
数学训练的，但如果你用 GPQA 来评估它，GPQA
是一个包含生物、
化学和物理问题的基准测试，那么这个
模型表现得非常好。嗯，
这很有意思，更智能的
模型确实更智能。” 他
当时做出了这样的预测：
如果国会
继续推进相关工作，6 个月内，仅通过数学训练，我们就能使人类
在科学方面达到人类水平
。 我们当时就想，
“我的天哪，这太疯狂了。”
当时这里处于极其严格的封锁状态。
感觉就像我们找到了一种方法，
可以坐下来仔细查看
模型的输出结果，然后我们惊叹道：“哇，
这简直是我见过的最智能的东西之一
。我
以前从未见过这样的模型推理方式。”   就
好像如果这种模式发展成为
一种不断扩大规模的范式一样。 但
后来我们回头一看，就觉得
，你知道，GPQA 就像是，你
知道，博士级别的生物学、化学和
物理学。 我们当时就想，“啊，那
是什么？我们真的需要
专业水平。” 我们似乎一直在
改变
衡量标准。 是啊，那真是太棒了。
我记得早期 AP 生物课只是用来
检验
模型是否能做到这一点的基准测试。 但
正如你提到的，有趣的是，
OpenAI 发布的很多东西都以数学为重点。
数学之所以有用，是因为它
在某种程度上更容易客观验证。 因此，对于
我们早期训练的一些问题，
进行强化学习
和扩展数学推理范式会更容易
。 嗯，数学
在很多方面也很有用，你知道，它就
像是核心科学类型之一
。 但从很多方面来看，这只是
我们偶然关注到的一件事，但这并不
一定是我们
想要在研究中关注的最终结果。 就像
我们现在意识到的那样，“好吧，如果我们能把
这种方法应用到数学领域，我们能否将其扩展到
其他类型的科学领域、专业
工作领域，以及
对人类个人
层面有用的能力领域呢？” 所以我觉得数学更像是
证明过程，而不是最终
目标。
但你似乎说过，
如果某种东西能够长时间思考
，将事情分解成
步骤，并像解决非常
复杂的
数学问题那样逐一思考，那么这种能力确实可以
迁移过来。
这的确是一个值得大肆讨论的话题。
嗯。
所以，其中一些肯定会延续
下去。 推理的一般思路是
有用的。 但是，
在不同的领域，你也可能需要一些特定领域的技能、工具或推理方式。 例如
，对于编码来说，如果你想扩展编码代理，你需要能够
实际编写和执行代码以及
测试代码
。 因此，我们
在
评估和训练方面一直在思考的一件事是，
我们如何确保赋予模型
在该特定领域进行推理所需的技能、工具和能力
。 数学的一些优势是
可以转化应用的，但你可能还
需要一些特定领域的辅助工具才能
真正发挥其全部潜力。 就像是
，你知道，先接受普通
高中或文科教育，
然后再接受专业教育。
推理模型是一个非常
有趣的时刻，因为它
改变了我们对可能性的思考方式，
即使只有
一定量的计算能力，只要让
模型思考更长时间，并给
模型机会去提出
更复杂的答案，就能实现更多可能性。
O1 期间有没有发生什么让你感到惊讶的有趣事情？
所以，O1 的发布过程非常令人
兴奋，因为我们已经思考
推理范式很
长时间了，而且有些人
担心我们
不要过早发布它，因为
它感觉像是一种范式转变。 就像
我一开始说的那样，我们
以为在6个月内就能实现AGI，当时
一些早期的运行已经进行了。
所以，问题就变成了：
“好吧，我们如何负责任地推出这项技术
？我们如何测试这项
技术？” 在
O1 的初始发布审查期间，我们在进行一些
网络安全测试时，该模型就像是
突破
沙箱的首批示例之一。 我们曾就此事发表过文章。 嗯，
它原本应该在这个
Docker 容器中，在这次
夺旗战中，模型发现了
我们在
实现夺旗战
场景时存在的漏洞，然后它就爆发了。 我们当时
都想：“哦，不。
[笑声]
如果这个模型能做到这些，那它还能做到什么呢
？” 嗯，那感觉就像是感受到了通用人工智能（
AGI）的存在。 众多之一。 我觉得从那以后，又
出现了
许多类似的时刻，该模型
做出了一些非常令人惊讶、
聪明或新颖的事情，而这些事情是
我们做测试时根本没有想到的
。 然后你回来
查看成绩单和结果，
就会想：“哇，这些人
真聪明。他们真聪明。”
然后，我们认为非常重要的是要
发表这篇文章，并确保全世界都
知道这些模型可以做到这类
事情。   是的
。   在
01 号公告发布前有一段时间
。 很多人都觉得，
“唉，看来我们遇到瓶颈了。
几个月来什么都没
发生。” 然后 01 出来了，他们就
问：“什么是墙？”
把“撞墙”当成一种
错误的思考方式，真的太让人沮丧了。
我看到这样的帖子会很沮丧，
因为我会想：“伙计，如果你看看我们，
你会发现这个模型一直在改进，一直在
进步，而且还在不断
进步。它一直在
变得更好。看看
我们现在的研究路线图，我看不出任何
停止的迹象。一切都会越来越
好。今年将会是
疯狂的一年。很多
很棒的研究成果将会发布。
我认为这在
整个行业都是如此。所以，是的，如果说有什么
问题的话，那就是人们
对模型的期望真的太低了
。不过，
OpenAI 似乎经常发布一些新东西，
告诉大家我们正在朝着什么方向发展，
说这看起来很有意思。
有时候人们会忘记这一点，或者你会听到一些
传言，比如“Q*
Q*，伙计，
你们真有意思”。但是，
人们并没有意识到这一点。我不知道。
我觉得我们一直努力保持开放的态度，
告诉大家：“嘿，伙计们，以下是……” 一些
情节。 就像线条在向上延伸一样。   “
它们真的非常强大。” 我觉得
可能存在一种
误解，好像研究人员
不理解这些模型。他们认为这些
模型只擅长数学和
研究，不擅长处理
现实世界的事情。但我并不
这么认为。我认为，即使是
其他行业的从业者，比如那些转型
到 OpenAI 的人，也开始看到我们的
模型能够处理各种各样的
事情。我知道这看起来好像
研究人员在过度
吹捧模型。但
我觉得我们反而低估了
它们的威力。
你提到了通用人工智能（AGI）。如果我把
GPT-4
从 2023 年 3 月提前
到 2020 年，我想
人们会这么称呼它。而
现在我们对它有了截然不同的
看法。人们每天都在和人工智能对话
。他们会进行长时间的交流，
比如现在没人再谈论
图灵测试了。图灵测试曾经是一个没人
真正理解的概念。 他当时试图
解释，你知道，但现在我们
早已过了那个时期。
通用人工智能（AGI）有评估吗？
是的，模型通过了图灵测试，
却没人讨论。这有点
疯狂。
是的，我觉得
在很多情况下，模型几乎和人类无法区分。
嗯，就通用人工智能的测试而言，我的意思是，
我认为如果一个模型能够完成
经典的、最具经济价值的
工作，而且我认为人们越来越多地
将模型用于他们工作的大部分内容，我
认为关于
这种情况究竟何时
发生，将会存在很大的争议，但说实话，我感觉
Codex确实为我做了很多工作。
我很幸运能拥有
无限的代币，你知道，所以这是我
来这里工作的唯一理由。
[笑声]
请加入。是的
。
但是，我认为总有一天，
人们会意识到
他们正在将模型用于
他们工作的很多方面，以及
我们将看到的科学突破，或者
我认为 总有一天，
这些模型会变得无可辩驳，它们确实非常
强大。
数学专家们在
讨论这些模型在
这方面的进步，
物理学家们也在讨论如何运用它们，
我认为我们开始看到一些
真正的成果，这真是令人
兴奋。
是的。
你提到了
早期一些评估存在的问题。
很多评估都沿用了旧的
自然语言处理方法
等等，当我们
寻找衡量
成功的方法时，会发现其中一些评估过于
简单，以至于模型勉强
通过了那些基准测试，然后我们
不得不寻找新的评估类别
。这些评估是如何演变的？
过去，
我们的模型甚至连一些学术基准测试都
无法通过。比如，
高中或大学里常见的经典考试，或者一些
选择题。
随着模型变得越来越智能，我们必须
让测试越来越贴近现实。所以，
我们最初设定的基准之一是…… 我们
更公开地发布了一个
名为 Sweep Bench Verified 的基准测试，它测试
模型
在真实的 Python 代码库（例如 Django）中交互的能力，例如
完成 PR 等等，以及通过
单元测试。之后，我们进一步测试了
模型
在复杂环境中执行多步骤操作的能力，例如
在计算机上执行操作，以及执行
与现实世界（例如我们的
湿实验室和生物学工作）相关的操作。因此，我认为
随着时间的推移，随着模型的不断
改进，我们必须在评估的
长期性和
真实性方面更具雄心。而
这非常有趣，因为你必须始终
走在技术
进步的前沿。
所以，在谈到基准测试时，我想请你解释两个术语。
你经常会
听到“
基准测试”（benchmarking）。
是的，[清嗓子] 基准测试，我
想说的是，
如果有人训练模型只是为了在
某些
评估或基准测试中看起来不错，而不是真正地提升
模型的性能，那么这种做法就行不通了。 有用吗？我
觉得这通常没什么
帮助，因为你希望模型能够
胜任用户实际
想要做的事情。你不会只
关心它在
营销文案里看起来好不好，因为当用户
使用它时，他们会觉得，嘿，这跟
我预想的完全不一样。
所以，基准测试通常不好。基准测试
不好。是的
，我觉得我
听到的解释有点道理
：你有一定数量的计算
预算和时间，你打算花多少钱
。你可以把其中很大
一部分用来提升模型的
整体性能，或者我可以把
90%的资源都投入进去。这样，我的评估结果
在发布时看起来会非常出色。
有时我们看到有人
直接用这些评估结果。结果
出来后，你会觉得，哦，这
看起来是个很棒的模型。然后你
发现，
哦，它只擅长这个。
是的，这对用户来说体验很差。
用户。所以，我
认为OpenAI
研究项目做得相当不错的一点是，我们
非常注重严谨地
确保将资金投入到
真正重要的领域，用于通用模型的改进。
然后，你知道，最后我们会进行
一些评估进行比较。
嗯，但我们的目标不应该是“哦，我们
只是想在评估中表现出色”。我们
想要打造的模型能够
推动科学前沿或
工作前沿的发展，
诸如此类。嗯，我认为
Yakov也做得非常好，他在
整个研究
机构中贯彻了“我们应该真正做到科学
和诚实”的原则。这包括，你
知道，我们曾经发表过一些
模型并非最佳的结果。我们只是
想公布
真实情况，确保我们能够
非常准确地描绘出
模型的能力，然后尽可能地让
它们
在现实世界中发挥作用
。
你提到软件工程
基准测试是
现在可能不太有用的指标之一，我们经常听到“
饱和”这个词。请解释一下它的含义。
基准测试达到饱和状态时，就意味着
模型几乎能
正确通过所有题目，就像
在测试中接近100%的分数一样。
一旦基准测试达到饱和状态，
它的实用性就大打折扣，因为你无法
通过这个测试真正区分不同的模型。
这就像比较两个天才参加
高中数学考试一样。他们可能都能
及格，但这没什么
用，因为你试图区分的是
真正聪明的个体
。所以，挑战
始终在于如何制定越来越难、越来越
现实、越来越不饱和的基准测试，以便
随着时间的推移衡量模型，
并预测
未来的发展方向。那么，
现在该怎么做呢？如何
确定一个好的基准测试是什么
？
我认为最好的基准测试
是真正现实的，并且衡量的是
人们真正关心的东西。
我们最初尝试
做这件事，虽然已经过去一段时间了
，但我们发表的论文
叫做GDP评估。我当时对
这个想法感到非常兴奋。
我们当时面临的问题是，如何衡量模型与现实世界的交互能力。
我们不断训练出性能越来越好的
模型，但在 SweepBench 测试中，它们的表现却几乎
一样，因为它们都表现得
非常出色，仿佛我们已经
达到了该基准测试
所能衡量的极限。我们当时就想：“天哪，
我们根本不知道该如何衡量
人们实际想用我们的模型做什么
。”
就像美国劳工统计局
列出了所有热门职业以及
每个职业的主要任务一样，比如
金融分析师进行
投资尽职调查、撰写法律
备忘录，或者
根据研究成果撰写论文等等
。我们的
想法是，能否让模型处理
人们在
现实生活中可能遇到的任务，并结合他们当时的具体情况，
看看模型如何
解决这些任务。当时，
当我们用
这个基准测试最早的模型之一时，它的准确率只有不到
20%。 与
人类相比，模型在工作任务上的表现要差得多。
但我真的为我们机构感到骄傲，因为
我们意识到
应该发布这种新的方法来
衡量和预测现实
世界经济影响的进展。这对
很多经济学家来说都非常有用，
而且我们现在的模型也是最好的。
这很棒，因为我认为
当时
我们并没有在一些培训项目中真正投入到
现实世界的工作中，甚至
没有进行衡量
或跟踪。而现在，我们更加
关注如何让
这些模型对人们的
实际工作有用，比如对真正的科学家来说。
这就像一个
警钟，提醒我们或许也应该考虑
如何衡量事物
在现实世界中的使用情况。所以这
很棒。但现在我们觉得，好吧，这个
基准可能太简单了，因为它
非常具体，每个
提示都长达数百
字，比如“我希望你打开这个
电子表格，做这个更改，做
这件事，然后……”
计算结果并记录在备忘录里。
非常详细。我认为
下一步是如何让模型像现实世界
中的报告一样具有足够的模糊性。比如，
如果
经理问：“嘿，你能帮我运行一下这个
分析吗？”他们应该自己想办法，把所有信息整合起来，
运行
分析，然后给出输出结果。所以，
我们一直在努力寻找
更实际的方法来衡量
现实世界中的实际工作，无论是
个人科研还是
企业应用。与其
隐藏基准，不如
把它公开出来，这似乎很有道理。因为在
组织内部，你会觉得“好吧，这
不行”。
是的，这确实能激励研究
。我认为人们想知道
真相，想知道我们有哪些地方可以
做得更好，并
为用户提供更好的模型。
因此，了解差距非常有用。
你认为我们
目前的评估方法有哪些局限性
？
我认为工作类型…… 我们
现在与 Codex 合作，使用
最新的推理模型（例如 55），其
能力水平与 6 个
月前相比有了质的飞跃。
静态基准测试无法衡量
这些模型能够长时间高效运行的特性。
这些模型可以连续工作数天甚至数周
。在内部
研究方面，我们已经让模型
长时间运行以
完成任务。
自动化评估的一个问题是，它需要
在一定时间内运行并产生
结果才能进行分析。
我们现在衡量模型的许多方法
还包括观察
生产环境中的使用情况，以及
用户在实际应用中的使用情况，了解
他们如何使用模型以及能够完成哪些类型的
任务，因为
模型能够完成的工作量持续时间越来越
长。
例如，观察
长上下文模型的发展很有意思。
早期，各公司竞相宣称
“我们的模型可以运行很长时间”，
10万个词元，100万个词元，
随便什么数量。” 但当时并没有
对这种方法的效果进行充分的评估。
后来我们又遇到了“大海捞针”的问题，
也就是判断模型能否
找到某个词或其他内容。我觉得当时
人们都
以为这个问题已经解决了，
但其实并没有。问题在于之前的
基准测试不够完善。所以
我们需要更好的基准测试。而真正让模型有所
改进的，是不是因为
人们终于能够更
专注于解决这个问题，因为他们
理解了模型失败的原因？
是的，现在我们确实有了更好的
基准测试。
而且，这些问题有时也会
暴露出我们在
训练思路上的不足。举个例子，我们过去
认为，“重要的是在测试时
能往模型里塞多少上下文信息
。” 但现在看来，
你只需要把一堆文件放到
一个容器里，模型就可以像
搜索一样，在需要的
时候自动查找所需的信息。这种
搜索功能或者说工具，可以帮助我们确定
应该使用哪些上下文信息。 这样做比简单地把
所有内容都塞进
上下文更高效。如果我们
不亲自尝试，
并观察它
在各种基准测试中的表现，我们可能根本不会意识到这一点。所以，我认为
这让模型变得
更加实用，例如，
现在模型可以搜索
整个代码库，找到
你需要的文件，并理解
你修改的上下文。
对于许多工作场景也是如此，比如
Codex 的用户现在可以
上传他们的本地文件系统，或者
你
之前可能制作过与当前工作相关的 PowerPoint 文件或发送过 Slack 消息，
模型可以通过
工具调用来搜索这些上下文
。因此，我们不再受限于
你能塞进
上下文的内容量，因为模型可以进行搜索。
你有什么喜欢的评估吗？
我最喜欢的评估？我的意思是，GDP 评估是我
最喜欢的公开评估。
好的。
但我有很多内部评估。我
可以透露其中一个的名字。 它
叫 Houdini 测试台，我没法
再多解释了。
我的天，你知道我以前是
魔术师，对吧？所以，
不。
是的，我是。是的，我知道。
也许我不知道你能不能通过 Houdini 测试
台。
不，[嗤笑] 我可能通过不了 Houdini 测试
台。实际上，
我以前玩
一些早期视觉模型的时候，
就是用
魔术表演之类的照片，然后
看到这个。
这太酷了。是的，多模态
带来了一个全新的元素。嗯，
我记得 4.0 版本刚
发布的时候，
我们一群人坐在
楼顶，
实时语音模型的概念让我们大吃一惊。然后我们
就想，“我们该怎么评估这玩意儿呢？”
对吧？因为如果能实时进行语音交互，那么
用文本和代码在
电脑上做事的整个范式就完全被
颠覆了
。
那次发布会最有趣的地方在于，我们
当时公开说过，为了确保模型的安全性，我们实际上将
公开发布推迟了六周。4.0
？
是的，因为当时正值选举之前
。所以大家
非常担心，如果模型
能够用逼真的声音实时与你对话
，这会不会被
用来进行说服性宣传之
类的？
公司推迟发布以确保
我们能够完成所有测试并
内置缓解措施，从而确保
模型不会被用于此类
用途，这一点非常棒。随着这些模型变得多模态，
这似乎是一个非常
复杂的因素
。我记得早期的
GPT-4，也就是 GPT-4 Vision 版本，
你可以……我可以……是的，我的
字迹很糟糕。我可以写一个提示，它
突然就能给出答案。
然后你意识到，哦，提示里不是文本
，而是一个…… 视觉提示。然后，
对于音频模型，当你进行
音频输入和输出时，模型可以
模拟各种情况，并以
各种不同的方式执行操作。所以，这似乎真的让人头疼。
你到底该从哪里
开始思考如何
衡量这些呢？
是的，我的意思是，这需要大量的工作。
通常，对于任何此类情况，我们都会先思考
人类在这种情况下会怎么做。
比如，你需要一
组输入到模型中的数据，
以及一组需要
评估的输出。然后你可以逐步
构建，比如，我们能否自动化其中一些
步骤？我们能否构建一个新的平台来
大规模地测量这类数据？然后从
那里开始。但对于一些
原生多模态模型，
你就像是必须拆解大量的现有
基础设施，并使其正常工作。Sora
也是如此，
你知道，我们想要
确保视频不会过于逼真，
或者可能被用于不正当的用途。这
尤其需要从
安全角度构建一整套全新的技术栈。
评估和缓解措施，例如
在模型层面加入拒绝机制，以及监控
其在生产环境中的使用情况。
是的，这需要一套全新的
思维方式。
没错，关键在于
，当你开始思考如何确定评估的优先级时，何时才能判断某个评估方法是否有效，
或者只是简单地认为
某个评估方法已经饱和，需要进行下一个评估？
因为即使你可能并非
旨在针对某些
公开基准进行优化，你仍然需要
弄清楚哪些因素
对我们现在来说才是重要的。曾经有一段
时间，
OpenAI 在代码方面处于领先地位，但后来
并非如此。现在它又重新领先
，但那段
时期确实很艰难。是的
，我们尽量避免
过多地被公开基准所干扰，因为它们
可能会产生很多干扰。我认为，
我们内部有一个叫做 AGI
指数的东西，它的灵感来源于
CPI 或通货膨胀的概念，它包含一
篮子加权商品。
你们在追踪这些商品的价格
。对
我们来说，情况也一样，我们有
一系列评估指标，涵盖了
我们所有关注的核心领域，例如
对齐性、
安全性、功能等等。
这基本上就是你希望
模型达到的目标，我们会不断
迭代更新这个指标，使其
更接近
我们希望模型实现的复杂版本。
我们会在内部追踪这个指标，尽量避免被
一些公开的基准测试之类的东西分散注意力。我们
更注重的是将
不同领域的评估指标结合起来，这些领域涵盖了
我们关注的科学和
工作，以及安全性、对齐性，
并确保我们在
这个加权指标体系上不断取得进展。嗯，尽量
保持专注。
我们一直在关注
这些评估指标的演变，也一直在关注
模型的演变。我和
这里从事科学研究的人交流过，他们都是
活跃在科学领域的，不仅仅是
喜欢科学或
计算机科学的研究人员，还有
生物学、数学等领域的人。你能告诉我吗？
科学前沿评估的进展如何？因为我们
现在似乎即将
看到一些有意义的成果。
是的，我认为
我们的一些科学评估工作非常令人
兴奋。在过去的几个月里，
我们公布了几项不同层级的评估结果
。第一层级是
名为“前沿科学奥林匹克”的评估，
它类似于
我们之前举办的数学奥林匹克式评估，旨在衡量
模型
在生物、化学和
物理等学科中，类似高中奥林匹克竞赛题目的表现。这些题目的答案比较简短
，但仍然…… 都相当困难，而且
模型还不太好。
接下来我们开展的下一阶段是
前沿科学研究，它也是
公开的，人们可以运行它，
它衡量模型在多大程度上可以
帮助完成一些未完成的
生物学、化学和物理学论文。
所以，我们找了一些
这些领域的博士或教授，他们有一些
未发表的文本，比如
[清嗓子]他们论文的一部分，
然后把这些文本转换成评估模型，
给模型一些
输入数据或一些初始
起点，然后模型必须看看
它如何完成论文的其余部分，并根据
评分标准来判断它的表现如何
。 你知道，这开始
真正地衡量，好吧，模型是否
开始进行研究了？ 他们是否
使用了工具？ 诸如此类的事情。
最后，其中一项最终迭代
是检验该模型
在现实世界的湿实验室中的表现如何。
因此，我们与一家名为
Ginkgo Bioworks 的公司合作，该公司拥有许多
非常酷的自动化湿实验室机器人，
该模型必须优化
蛋白质合成方案。 其
理念是，该模型将生成一个
方案，然后他们将
在湿实验室中自动测试该方案，
在那里他们将放入
模型建议的试剂，然后
查看他们获得了多少蛋白质产量。 嗯，
这是针对一种
与卵巢癌药物相关的蛋白质，
或者说，这是该药物的一种模拟实验
。 一开始我们真的很
紧张，因为我们觉得
，建立人类基线有点
困难。 我们不知道这个模型能否
胜过它。 但我们永远不应该
低估这些模型，因为，你
知道，曲线非常
清晰。 每一个循环都变得越来越
好，超越了人类的
基准，然后设定了该
模型以每单位产量成本
生成这种蛋白质的最先进水平。 我认为
这仅仅是个开始。如果我们给
这些模型一些优化问题，比如，
如何
尽可能降低疫苗的生产成本，或者如何
合成
对药物至关重要的蛋白质，
模型就可以不断地利用
现实世界的输入来优化这些方案。
这是我们第一次
降低与
现实世界相关的评估风险，就像
[嗤笑]
我们不用等待一段代码
运行一样。 我们当时正在等待机器人
完成实验，以便记录
合成了多少蛋白质。 是的
，我认为这些模型将为
我们带来很多科学发现。 这将会
非常有趣。
嗯，那很令人兴奋，因为
我觉得 GPT-5 就是这样，它还没有
经历过任何“如何
成为一名科学家”之类的过程。 现在这些模型已经有了
很大的进步，你也积累了
更多的实际经验
。
是的，那甚至还不是我们
最好的型号之一。 它就像一个早期的
推理模型。 嗯，所以我觉得是的，
所有这些因素都会叠加起来，比如我们
会有更好的预训练、更好的
强化学习和后训练，而且我们会
在测试时更好地使用这些模型，从而真正发挥它们的
能力。 我认为下一代
评估的真正意义在于，如何让
这些模型在现实世界中采取行动，
为我们解决一些
人类需要很长时间才能解决的未解难题，比如
我们一直
未能投入足够精力去
攻克的一些科学难题。 这就好比，现在我们有了这么多
可以消耗计算资源来
为我们解决问题的代理，我们要努力
引导它们朝着有用的方向发展。   但这似乎也
带来了
新的挑战。 你认为
评估会变得更加
复杂吗？   是的
，我们队里有句谚语：
痛苦是护城河。 我真的
认为现实世界中的很多操作（笑）
将会成为
衡量模型性能的瓶颈，
因为
即使只是从数字领域开始，
我们也需要做很多搭建脚手架和基础设施的工作来运行
这些模型，比如现在如果你想测试
Codex 的性能如何，就会发现
模型正在调用 API。 这就像
在你的电脑和
浏览器中进行操作一样。 它正在为你制作工艺品。
它负责编写、运行和执行
那段代码。 嗯，
测量这个模型要复杂得多，而且这还
只是数字模型。 现在，如果你想让他们
衡量模型如何
与物理世界互动，你需要
各种各样的操作和物流，你需要
一个非常流畅的流程来
了解如何大规模部署这些东西，
嗯，是的，我认为很多
工作实际上正在从
理论、数学甚至编程转向其他方面。
我觉得现在人们不太会编程了
。 他们只是询问 Codex，而且工作重心更多地转向
规划、
运营、实体事务，或者
至少我的工作已经朝着这个方向发生了很大的变化
。 嗯，
那些事情都很难。
其实很容易，就像
在角落里写点什么一样。 嗯，
当你需要管理所有
这些运营和物流时，那就难多了。
这令人兴奋，但
挑战之一似乎在于，这些不再只是
简单的评估了。 它们需要更多的
计算资源，需要更多的时间。 当
你尝试进行长期评估时，
你知道，评估周期很长。 你需要等待很
长时间才能得到结果。   是的
，当然。 所以，
提出评估方案并
大规模运行它们需要更多的工作，而且，你
知道，这项工作需要更长的
时间，我们就无法快速获得信号。
所以，我们必须加大对尺度
定律的投入，这样我们就可以预测，好吧，
如果某一天模型看起来是这样的，
那么我们就可以预测7天后它
会变成这样，并得出一些
趋势，以便我们能够
更快地获得信号。 否则，我们就只能
被困在那里等待一周才能
得到更新，这并不是
最有效率地利用时间的方式。
每次有新型号
上市，我都会设定一些基准和测试方法，以了解它对
我个人的实用性。 这也是
我告诉那些经营
企业或其他事务的人的一件事：要
考虑自己的评估，评估结果会
告诉你事情的进展情况，因为
有时人们可能会尝试一些东西，
比如他们可能在 6 个月前尝试了聊天 GPT，
然后说：
“啊，它不好。它没有做到这一点。”
他们没有意识到事物变化有多快。
对于如何制定基准，您有什么建议
？
是的，我的意思是，如果事物发展得非常
快，每隔几周就会发生变化，
我觉得人们对这些变化的认识还不够
深入。在我的工作中，我是
世界上最早接触到一些
最强大模型的人之一，所以我对通用人工智能（
AGI）非常了解，我认为
进步的速度要快得多。
我看到了什么？
[笑声]
我见过不少好模特，伙计。   是的
，但进展速度
比人们想象的要快得多。
老实说，我认为最好的评估方法就是
给狗粮做实验或者用模型来检验。
人们应该尽可能多地使用这些模型
。 即使
他们认为模型
在某一周的表现不佳，他们也应该在
下周再次尝试。 这
大概会奏效。
我认为，对于
人工智能领域之外的人来说，显而易见的一点是，优秀的
尖端人工智能公司是如何在内部使用这些
工具的，这也是为什么人工智能的发展速度越来越快、
能力越来越强的原因。
是的，我基本上是想让模型先对所有东西进行一次初步
测试。
嗯。   是的，
我同意。 比如，你知道，
发送 Slack 消息，
了解接下来要进行什么实验
，以及任何管理方面的事情，运营、
物流，比如让模型进行
第一次测试。 如果模型
不好，我们就想办法把
它纳入评估中。
我对计算机使用
评估功能感到兴奋。 仅仅观看
Codex 在计算机应用方面的表现，就
比八个月前的情况有了光年的提升。
而且这些方面似乎只会越来越好，越来越快
。 我的
预测是，到
今年年底，它使用我的电脑的速度
和效率可能会超过我。   是的
。 是的，我也这么认为。 这些模特
比你有一些优势，对吧？ 就像
他们可以调用
连接器或插件一样，这是一种比
你在
电脑上点击
进入服务、了解每个
页面、然后来回复制数据快得多的通信方式
。 或者甚至可以编写一些
服务来调用该 API 或 MCP 或
其他任何东西。 这就像是
人类比模型付出了更多努力。 所以这种
模型具有这种优势。 而且，
如果经过训练，模型可以更快地
导航浏览器或
桌面，无论是
通过辅助功能树还是通过
代码。
所以模型比我们更有优势。
而且我认为，很长一段时间以来，都
没有什么
真正有效的产品部署。 然而，就像我们
前段时间推出的操作员和 ChatGPT 代理一样，
它们对于展示
这种可能性确实很有用，但
这些模型的延迟实在
太高了。 他们动作超级慢。
我不认为人们
现在会大规模地使用它们，但我们现在已经
达到了一个临界点，让
模型帮
我读取 Slack 消息，或者安排
一堆日历邀请，以及
优化会议室，这些操作比我
自己做要快得多。 我觉得是的，人们还没有做好
准备。 此外，很多人还没有
尝试过这些东西，因为它们都是
最近才推出的，但是每个人都
应该去买一台电脑，使用插件，
安装所有能
加快速度的插件和连接器。
到那时你一定会大吃一惊。
我们来谈谈前沿评估吧。   是的
。 因此，前沿评估团队的目标
是衡量和预测
OpenAI 前沿模型的进展，以便更好地了解我们目前所处的位置、未来的发展方向
，并尝试
与世界分享这些信息。
我认为团队一直努力的方向之一就是
尽可能多地发布和开源项目。 所以，你知道，
我们帮助开源的一些评估工具
包括 SweetBench Verified，它
帮助衡量编码方面的进展；MLE
Bench，它衡量
模型训练其他模型的能力，并
跟踪
我们模型中机器学习工程技能的进展；
PaperBench，它衡量
模型
复现
ICML 或 ICLR 等顶级机器学习论文的能力；
以及 GDP eval，它帮助
衡量模型在
40 多个职业的实际任务中的表现。 所有这些的目标都是，
你知道，这些模型现在可能看起来不太好
，但如果你绘制出它们如何
随着每一代模型而增长的图表，你会发现
结果随着每一代模型的迭代而改善
，而人们常常会说，
“哦，我预计这需要
一年左右的时间。” 他们喜欢“
嗯”。
他们
预计
达到基准饱和所需的时间会更长。
甚至我自己或我团队成员的
预测也常常不够乐观，无法应对
事物变化如此之快的速度。
所以我觉得我们只是在努力为
世界做贡献，帮助人们了解什么
是可能的。 我认为其中一些
研究加速评估报告
尤其有趣。
就像我们刚开始的时候，我们进行了一项
名为 OpenAI 研究
面试评估的评估，它只是把
我们向申请加入 OpenAI 的人提出的研究人员问题整理
成一个评估。 该模型
很快就完成了测试。   感觉她
现在肯定能通过我们的面试。 嗯，我认为这
引发了一系列
后续问题，比如我们如何
确保人们在面试中不作弊，
以及我们如何真正
衡量研究人才？
但我认为所有这些都非常有用，
因为衡量内部进展就像是衡量
模型不断
改进速度的杠杆作用的一种方式。 就像是
进步速度加快了一样。 嗯，我
认为有办法衡量模型的
进展是非常
有用的信息。
我听说，之前流传的一些评估报告中
，有些
题目实际上存在错误。 那确实是
某些评估中存在的问题。 其中
一些公开的
题目
实际上无法达到
一定的分数上限。 如果你真的这么做了，那
实际上是因为你正在用这些
数据进行训练。 人们看了之后
发现，“哦，
这其实并不是正确答案。”
是的，
我认为这是很多公开基准测试都存在的问题。 就像这样，
最初进行 SWE 基准测试验证的原因
是，我们想运行 SWE 基准测试，结果发现
一半的问题要么是程序
损坏，要么是规格不符。
你知道，业内人士会
公布这方面的数据，以此作为衡量业绩
好坏的指标之一。 我们当时
就想，“好吧，我们至少应该尝试去
解决这个问题。” 然后分享出去，这样我们
就能有更好的衡量标准。 嗯，但我
认为公开的
基准测试可能并不总是像我们希望的那样经过
实战检验，原因之一是，
它们往往像是
实验室里的某个人（比如学术实验室里的某个人）想出了
一个好主意，
想写篇论文，但他们从未在
大规模环境下运行过评估，比如生产环境的
训练运行或发布前的全面
评估。而当
你在大规模环境下运行这些测试时，它们就会
崩溃或失效，你才能
发现所有这些漏洞。
所以我认为，在实验室里，更
接近产品，这本身就是一种强制
机制，可以确保
你的测量质量非常高。
因为我们做这些测试不是为了
在论文里看起来漂亮，而是为了确保它能够有效
运行，因为它必须在
大规模环境下对我们的系统有效运行，所以这在某种程度上
迫使我们追求高质量。   似乎可能会
出现的情况之一是，这些模型
有时能力非常强，
有时它们非常擅长解决问题，但
它们会选择最懒惰的方式，直接
给出
记忆中的答案，而不是解决问题。
我们看到，比如计算
一个字符或单词有多少个字母，或者一个单词有多少个单词
等等，通常情况下，如果
你用正确的方式提示模型，它就能给出
正确的答案，但如果你没有用
正确的方式提示，它就会直接
给出一个答案。
是的，这引出了各种各样
有趣的
概念。比如，其中一个
概念就是记忆，它指的是
模型实际上知道
答案，不需要思考
或推理就能解决问题，就像
复述它已经知道的东西一样。这
使得测量结果不太
有用，因为你只是在衡量
你是否恰好用
大量数据进行过训练，而不是衡量
模型是否真正学习了你想要衡量的技能、
工具或能力。
避免这种情况的一种方法是，尽量保持
数据的干净和规范，不
包含任何基准测试或
你想要衡量的评估。这有助于
解决你提出的第一个问题。这
是一方面。
另一方面，
模型可能会通过
奖励机制或作弊来
解决评估问题。这很大程度上取决于
评估设计的规范性，
你需要大规模地测试这些模型，
看看是否存在任何作弊行为，并
确保你
测试的环境不存在这些作弊行为。
模型可以
做到这一点。 这就需要大量的
质量控制，以确保
评估过程不会过于容易被破解。
嗯，是的。
是的，因为似乎有些
非常简单的模型，比如小学数学之类的，
如果你
稍微改变一下，一些
早期的模型就会出错，给出
错误的答案，而
实际上它们有能力解决这个问题。 但它
却说：“哦，这个我搞定了。”
然后，你知道，这种情况就发生在了，
比如，我应该开车去
洗车吗？ 你遇到问题了。   是
啊，是啊，是啊。 所以模型可能会
被欺骗。 我觉得这个模型好像
不喜欢它没能取得好成绩，就
好像它应该更
聪明一些。 就像我们希望
模型能够更稳健地抵御
欺骗一样。 但这与
能力获取的概念，
或者说以
最佳方式衡量模型的概念也有关联，这
对于我们的安全测试来说尤其重要。
例如，如果你想衡量
该模型在发现
漏洞或
执行一些网络安全
任务方面的能力。 你要确保模型
不是被问题本身所迷惑。
这样才能真正衡量出真正的
能力。 因此，我们需要进行大量的
快速调整，例如更换
线束，有时甚至需要进行
微调，以使模型能够
最大限度地应对挑战，
以确保，
如果我们发现“哦，这个模型
在某些非常危险的能力方面表现不佳”。 在
我们得出这个结论之前，还需要一些时间来进一步确认
。
我小时候很喜欢读《
布朗侦探百科全书》的故事，那些
小小的谜题需要你自己去解开
。 至于 GPT-4，我会编写一些
自定义的答案，以防有人
已经把所有这些答案都泄露出去了
。 但那样
做很麻烦。 想到
现在我可以给模型生成一些东西
或者提出一些新的评估方法，就令人兴奋不已。 那么
这些模型现在对我们有多大帮助呢？
嗯，
它们有点用处。
好的。
嗯，我认为我们正处于
模型开发的这个阶段，
有时候
输出结果还不够完善。   是的
。
他们需要人工质检或
监督，以确保质量
仍然很高，并且我们不会被
欺骗。 所以，我认为人们
有时会惊讶于我们在评估中仍然
有大量的人工干预和
参与，因为
你知道，评估数据的水平可能
低于训练数据，而你
想确保
你测试的每一个点，每一个数据点，
都是非常高质量的。 嗯，
所以，在某些方面，
人情味会显得格外美好。
我们看到一些有趣的趋势，即与
人工智能真正相关的工作似乎
更受欢迎，因为人工智能
提高了人们的生产力。 你们是如何
追踪这些数据的？ 你如何寻找
你认为会受到
影响的领域？   是的
，这些都是非常棘手的
问题。 嗯，
我
认为人们还没有意识到
我们的模型能够完成多少工作，
以及它们在各种工作中能够以多快的速度完成工作
。 嗯，
目前这些模型大多还只能胜任
任务，而不能胜任工作。 一份
工作包含的内容远不止一项任务。
正确的？ 就像你必须弄清楚
你想做什么工作，应对各种
不确定性，就像你可能要和
同事合作
并进行沟通一样。
然后，你可以先确定
你想完成的任务，然后把这个任务交给一个
模型。 而
我们现在就处于这样一个阶段，我的意思是，
即使在我的工作中，模式是
为我完成单个任务，但我
仍然要进行大量的思考和
计划等等。 而且
我认为人们甚至都没有意识到这一点
。 我觉得
软件和研究领域的人比我其他行业的一些朋友更了解
模型的运作能力，或者说，他们更清楚模型的强大之处
。 我希望人们能
多尝试一下这些模型，看看效果如何，因为
那些先尝试一下的人，
会开始真正理解它们。 嗯，但我
认为这些模型
在某个时候也将能够做到像委托这样的事情。 嗯，
或许不会太远了。 嗯，就是
弄清楚要做什么，应对各种
模糊不清的情况，比如编写
模型执行所需的规范。 人们
真的应该开始思考，
在
人工智能高度发达的世界中发生了什么？即使只是对于
数字
工作，模型也能想出
要做什么，执行它，就像
与现实世界互动一样。
你知道，
现在有很多企业，比如
独角兽公司，它们
主要依靠人工智能和少数员工来
创造所有
价值。
嗯，
所以我觉得这里有个问题
，那就是，我们是否意识到
这件事的规模有多大？
我个人认为，机会
空间正在扩大。 我认识的每个人
，尤其是那些最擅长使用 AGI 的人
，那些一直使用 Codex 等工具的人，
现在都做得更多了。 他们现在效率更高了，
因为他们不必再亲自完成那些任务
和工作，因为人工智能越来越擅长
处理某些工作，比如，太好了，
现在我需要完成五项工作，因为我可以
做更多。 我认为我们应该意识到，我们
所能达到的潜在范围比
我们想象的要大得多。 我认为这些工具
只是帮助我们更快地达到目标，而不是
缩小目标范围。
我认为可能是多种
因素混合造成的。   是的
。
即使你有一些可以
加快文书工作的模型，想想看，就像
药物的临床试验一样，对吧？
感觉你们花了几个月的时间
收集整理这些
文件，比如几百页的文件，
说明他们为什么应该能够进行
审判。 他们喜欢把申请提交给美国食品药品监督
管理局（FDA）。 还有大约 35% 的几率
因为
出错或遗漏某些东西而被拒绝。 他们会
进行修改。 最后你就可以进行
审判了。 你知道，这些流程虽然
很好，但就是耗时太长。
然后试验就是，你知道，你
有一个病例组和一个对照组之类的，
然后你记录症状，
跟踪这些症状，就像
长时间记录发生的事情，
然后进行大量的数据分析。
很多工作只是文档记录
、数据分析或者非常
传统的数字工作。 我认为，如果
模型能够帮助加速各个方面的发展
，例如医疗、能源、
制造业、政策研究、
教育等等，这将极大地
促进各个领域的进步。 希望我们能拥有
更快、更便宜、更好的商品。
这对人们来说真的很有好处。 这
对个人消费者来说非常好
。 所以，我认为这是一件值得
人们感到兴奋的事情
。 但是，我们应该认真思考
如何以一种深思熟虑且负责任的方式来应对向
那个世界的过渡
。
出色的。
谢谢你，奇吉纳。
谢谢邀请。